hi my name is Karthik family I'm in
sixth grade and I attend hillside junior
high in Boise Idaho
P&V needs to be aware of the environment
our generation consumes much more
resources than all the past generations
that is life building nature preserves
like this one and body scene is
essential in preserving the natural
ecosystem I'm so litems the wonderful
pictures of continue to inspire all of
us I would trade places with them
because of the immense sense of
adventure he had and how his pictures
were instrumental in the formation of
many parts and nature preserves if
someone gave me a free ticket to go
anywhere I would go to Alaska I'm
particularly eager to see the Northern
Lights
and I'm also go to see them you need the
diversity of wildlife such as grizzly
bears and the mass migration of Korea
but if that happens once a year we all
know that volcanoes can sometimes
contain a lake inside there Phaedra's
did you know that there exists a crater
lake that in turn has another volcanic
protrusion inside it which encloses
another case early in essence this is a
crater lake inside another apparently
tell me where this lake is and what the
name of the legacy
did I stop you dad this lake is Lake
Taal and Luzon Island of the Philippines
if I was in charge of hearth for one
single day and assuming that I had the
power and authority to do whatever image
I would remove all national boundaries
in order to make another beautiful
which blooms only once while these
flowers bloom they attract the whitening
you